You were a strange kid. I
appreciate your enthusiasm.
[Music]
Please stay away from me. Excuse me. [
Music] You're
good at French. I'd like to ask you to pay the bill. Can
someone who understands Japanese please tell me? That's your level. That's good. I
'm your friend. Do
n't worry.  You're not an idiot. I'm
meeting you for the first time in 3D. My name is Frank Bessou. I'm
Muriel's older brother who you just dumped.
Contrary to the rest of you, I'm in Tokyo on business. It's a
nice place, isn't it?  Is Japan a
business?
Well, that's not the problem.
It's your actions. [Music] The worst sin in this world is The
second worst is
letting people down.
If you want to be with that girl, just the two of you,
Muriel.  How about teaching someone the essence of romantic comedy? It's a
simple idea, right? I'm so excited.